[Musique]
nous voici au château de chamerolles un
jouet de la renaissance bâti au xvième
siècle par lancelot premier du lac il
est aujourd'hui propriété du département
du loiret alors ce n'est pas tant
l'histoire de ces propriétaires qui nous
intéresse mais plutôt l'histoire de ce
qu'on y faisait à la renaissance vous
allez le voir certaines coutumes et
pratiques de l'époque risque de vous
surprendre
[Musique]
et je vous propose tout de suite de
remonter le temps prenons le chemin de
la promenade des parfums du château
jonathan savary vous êtes le chargé de
programmation de de ce château l'idée de
cette promenade des parfums c'est de
montrer comment on prenait soin de son
corps la renaissance à l'époque la
toilette elle ressembler à quoi alors
xvième siècle en fait on prenait sa
toilette presque en public dans une
chambre finalement à côté de son lit
comme ici par exemple dans une baignoire
qui ressemble à celle ci n'y les noirs
ronseaux forme de tonneau
on pouvait passer presque trois heures
dans le bain sans aucun problème et dans
l'on pouvait s'y mettre la distillation
de plantes du jardin par exemple donc
des sorts des visées essentielle qui
permettait justement d'agrémenter le
bain est aussi de permettre au corps de
se protéger des maladies parce qu'on
croyait que les maladies étaient
présentes dans l'air on pensait qu en
fait plus on été parfumées plus on
contrer les maladies
au xviie siècle il ya plus de baignoires
absents et ménard complète donc on a
plus de ben en fait par immersion on va
la remplacer tout simplement parce qu'on
appelle une toilette sèche donc la toile
et c'est chez ce petit morceau de toile
on a fait une toilette qui ressemble
plus grosso modo un gant de toilette
d'aujourd'hui on va lui mais que tu es
simplement avec de l'eau parfumée de
cete guerre et on va en fait c'est
nettoyer les mains et le visage
simplement les parties visibles du corps
[Musique]
alors cette promenade des parfums elle
se poursuit jusqu'à nos jours et le clou
du spectacle pour le visiteur c'est cet
orgue à parfum qu'est ce que c'est alors
effectivement le regard parfum c'est ce
bureau en fait du parfumeur du début du
xxème siècle où le parfumeur en fait se
place au milieu il ya différentes
essences de parfums à disposition et
c'est à partir de ces différentes
essences qui va pouvoir justement
concocté les différents parfums qui vont
être mis sur le marché par la suite
alors c'est au regard parfum c'est pas
rien c'est un petit trésor je vous
propose tout de suite de découvrir un
trésor de patrimoine c'est parti
nous voici à présent dans la chapelle du
château une chapelle converti en temple
protestant la renaissance c'est un
édifice qui a connu une histoire
mouvementée on peut le dire
effectivement chapelle devenu temple
protestant d'où on peut voir en fait des
inscriptions et les peintures de cette
époque là qui ont été cachés juste avant
la révocation de l'édit de nantes est
redécouverte que récemment finalement au
20e siècle
et c'est un lieu de passage toujours
pour les protestants oui c'est une sorte
de lieu de pèlerinage on a quelques
protestants qui viennent ici se
recueillir dans ce temple pour voir en
fait c'est peinture qui sont à ce jour
les plus anciennes peintures protestante
connu en france
[Musique]
cette visite se termine comme elle a
commencé par une promenade cette fois ci
dans les jardins du château c'est sophie
pérou qui les accompagnent la
responsable de ce château alors à la
renaissance dans ses allées ou flâner on
se promenait bien sûr mais chaque espace
avait sa fonction bien précise oui oui
les jardins à la renaissance avait trois
fonctions principales nourrir les hommes
avec les deux carré de potager que nous
avons le plaisir le divertissement avec
le labyrinthe et le préau et enfin
démontrer le pouvoir avec le carré des
broderies et le carré des plantes rares
nos âmes il se gare et des plantes rares
il servait à quoi alors il servait à
démontrer la puissance du propriétaire
qui pouvait à la fois acquérir des
essences de pays lointains et qui
pouvait se permettre de les acclimater
voilà dans nos contrées
typiquement ici on a un palmier ce qui
peut paraître très anecdotique mais à
l'époque seul un chapelain voilà pouvait
se permettre ça
[Musique]
alors bien sûr si vous voulez voir toute
la splendeur de ses jardins en fleurs il
faudra programmé une visite au printemps
en attendant le château et ses sept
hectares de parcs et jardins reste
ouvert trente mille visiteurs s'y
rendent chaque année